نبدا معك جوني هذه المره باعتبار ان
الساعه الماضيه شهدت تطورات ميدانيه لها
علاقه بالقصف والغارات الاسرائيليه على
اي المنطقه وبعضها قريب من حيث
تتواجد صحيح حسن يمكن القول ان الاوضاع
هنا تستمر على توترها من جهه عمليات حزب
الله وابرزها اليوم العمليه التي قال انها
جاءت كرد اولي على اغتيال صالح العاروري
ومن جهه ثانيه الغارات الاسرائيليه
المستمره على عدد كبير من البلدات
الحدوديه والقصف المدفعي على مروحه واسعه
من البلدات الحدوديه وما بينهما الكثير من
الترقب لما يمكن ان تحمله الساعات المقبله
بالنسبه لحزب الله حتى هذه اللحظه اعلن عن
تنفيذه ثلاث عمليات باتجاه المواقع
العسكريه الاسرائيليه تبقى العمليه الابرز
تلك التي حصلت صباحا ب تجاه مقر قياده
التحكم والمراقبه الجويه في جبل ميرون
وكانت طبعا عمليه مختلفه عن سياق العمليات
التي ينفذها حزب الله انطلاقا من الاراضي
اللبنانيه وهو برر بانها تاتي كرد اولي
على اغتيال صالح العاروري قبل خمسه ايام
في قلب الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت واسهب حزب
الله كما استمعنا بشرح الاهميه العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه لهذه النقطه
بالتالي يمكن القول ان الحزب سعى الى
توجيه ضربه قاسيه للجانب الاسرائيلي
والتاثير على مساله الطلعات الجويه
والمراقبه الجويه للجانب الاسرائيلي في
هذه المناطق الحدوديه وغيرها من المناطق
الاخرى حزب الله ايضا استهدف مستوطنه
المطله والموقع العسكري في مستوطنه المطله
وتجمعات للجنود الاسرائيليين في ثكنه
هونين الرد الاسرائيلي كان ردا عنيفا من
خلال غارات جويه على عيت الشعب على يارون
على بلده برج الملوك غير البعيده من هنا
بالاضافه الى غارات جويه استهدفت نقاط
اخرى من بينها قبل اقل من ساعه غاره في
نقطه بين الطريق الواصل بين بلدتي العديسه
ورب الثلاثين واسفرت عن دمار كبير في احد
المنازل القصف المدفعي لم يكن اقل عنفا
باتجاه نقاط مختلفه هنا في المناطق
الحدوديه كان في القطاع الشرقي حيث نحن او
في القطاع الاوسط وايضا في القطاع الغربي
شكرا لك جوني طانيوس من مرجعيون